【OP】
こんにちは
ドクタアァァァァァァ･･･
はじめだ
皆さん紙粘土知ってますか？
紙粘土
というものなのだ･･･
GA☆
これ･･･
使ったことありますか？
紙粘土というものは普通の粘土とは違って
これ開封して形を作って放置すると
固形物になってしまう
つまり紙粘土があれば
どんな形の固形物でも
作ることが実質的に
お、可能でございます
そこで！
合計！
紙粘土を！
1260個準備してしまいました！
おわあっ！
っはっはっはっは～っ！
はっはぁぁぁぁぁー･･･
僕は今までの人生で
紙粘土で色んな物を作ってきたんですけども･･･
今回は
紙粘土で
家を作ってみようと思います
紙粘土で家を作れることはまあ
理論的には可能なんですけども
いくら固形物とはいえ
強度というものが存在します
なので紙粘土で家を作ったとしても
重すぎて
どれん！ってなるかもしれないし
逆にうまいこと作ればもう
綺麗な紙粘土のお家が出来るかもしれない
で、多分普通に建てても無理なので
一応こういう金具みたいなのを買って
紙粘土の補強をしていきながら
ちゃんとこう見た目はね
完全に紙粘土のお家だよ♪
みたいな感じで作っていければいいなと
思っております！
果たして！
紙粘土のお家は作ることは出来るのか？
ではいこう！
いや無理だと思うんだよなー･･･
いやいややりますけどね？
ああ痛ぁ！
はい、というわけで
紙粘土1260個出しました！
でこれ紙粘土今２種類あるんですけど
これがちょっと
重めの
強度が高い紙粘土
でこちらが
軽くて
よく伸びる･･･紙粘土
２種類の粘土があるんですけども
家の
下の部分は
なるべく硬い粘土を使って固めていって
で上の部分、屋根とかは
えー軽い紙粘土で
作っていこうと思います
ではいこう！！！
はい、では早速作っていきます！
まずは
作る紙粘土のお家の間取りを
決めていきましょう
えーとあまり大きい家を作ろうと
思いすぎると
足りなくなっちゃうんで
１LDKとも言わずの多分
作っていきます！
ああでもやっぱすごいな
ちゃんと
ウゴ・ケル
これで好きな形を作って
放置しておくと固まります
（ステップ１：土台作り）
どんどんやっていきまーす
※早送り
空耳「流れれば？」
空耳「あてつけ」
※早送り
はい、というわけで間取りは完成しました！
だいたいこれぐらいの大きさだったら
1260個の紙粘土で
足りると
思います！
でこっからちょっと
積み重ねていきましょう！
はい、で今ちょっと
こういう感じで立たせていったんですけども
多分
この上にさらに積み重ねていくと絶対倒れるんで
１番下の土台の粘土に
網をこう･･･
食い込ませておいて
補強しながら建てていきます
※早送り
いやいいっすね
紙粘土なんで
網がちゃんと
埋まっていきます
うん強度的には全然問題ないと思います
いきまぁす！！
※早送り
※もやし匠の技術をとくとご覧あれ
一応これで土台は
多分大丈夫だと思います
このままちょっと積み重ねていくんですけども
一応ここが
玄関の
予定でございます
どんどん建てていきましょう！
※早送り
土台となる大きな粘土の設置は
終了しました
これが基本的に土台になります
一応隙間なく
なるべく時間をかけて丁寧に
重ねていったので
あとは残りの800個のこの紙粘土を
いかに
乗せて
崩れないうちに
家まで、完成させれるかが
ポイントでございます
ふぅぅー･･･
頑張ります！
柔らかい
軽い方メチャクチャ柔らかいっす
何かこれなら何かもう
網とかに･･･
ペトペトくっつけとけてもいい
レベルです
え、メッチャ軽い！
見えた！
※もやし匠のハッタリかもしれないけど早送り
よっしゃあ･･･
※BGMはゆったりしてるけど早送り
※あ、金具が倒れた↑
※気づいてもやし匠↑
※もやし匠気づいて↑
※気づいてホンマに↑
※あ、匠が修復完了しました
うっ！
はぁ･･･はぁ･･･
はい、というわけで一通り壁は
完成しました
ちょっと高さはバラバラなんですけども
高さは屋根が完成して
屋根を乗せてから
こう、足していこうと思います
ちょぉっと待ってくれ！
（もやし匠のバカがバレました）
これ屋根が１番難しくね？
だってだってだっても多分、だって、え、待って･･･
待って屋根どうすればいい？
多分屋根はもうこの
ペタペタ作っててもダメなんで
屋根は別で作って
作った屋根をこの上に
バァン！って置こうと思います
はい、というわけで
屋根が！
完成しました･･･
多分紙粘土だけの強度だと
屋根は無理なんすよ！
紙粘土だけだと無理なんすよ！
多分･･･もう固まっても
乗せた瞬間バキッてなっちゃうんで
これ･･･紙粘土に･･･見えて
下にダンボールを
ひいております
これをこのまま
家の上に
乗せようと
思います！
えっ･･･
あっ･･･やばい！
やばい！
あ、いけるいける！
せぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇ
の
あっ･･･
（煙突です）
よし･･･
というわけで！
紙粘土の家･･･
完成しましたああああ！！
（雪だるまがポイントだから　byもやし匠）
（もう３月だけどここポイントだから　byもやし）
はい
で、大事なのは実際に入れるかどうかです
これ入れなかったらもう元も子もないですからね･･･
お邪魔しまーす！
ああっ！
入れる！
寒いけどホントちゃんと家として出来てると思います
ほらちゃんともう壁
この壁壁壁
全部ちゃんと壁として
成立しています
で窓（に見えるのは壁）
ほら窓から顔が出せます
良かった頑張って･･･(涙)
入れましたあああああ！！
あはっ･･･
犬小屋かよ
（もやし匠すばらしい）
デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑デ↓d (ry
子供が遊ぶ家くらいのサイズには
出来てるんではないでしょうか
はい！というわけで今日は
大量の紙粘土で家を作りました！
大変でした･･･ｗ
そして！
今回ですねー
CMなど色々出演した
「私立スマホ中学」の企画の一環で
わたくし、はじめしゃちょー･･･
理科の！
先生ということで
今回、この動画を･･･作りました！
で今回ですねー
この「紙粘土で家作ってみた」以外の
様々な
実験もやっていますので
是非皆さんそちらも
ご覧下さい！
そしてわたくし
はじめしゃちょー
理科担当の先生以外にも
総勢20名以上の！
すばらしい先生たちがいますので！
是非！他の先生の授業も！
見てください！
どれも面白いと思います！
動画の概要欄から、チェックしてみてください！
皆･･･
無駄な実験なんて無いんだよ･･･
/フニャリ\
やることに意味があるんだ！！
「今日の格言　byもやし匠」
【ED】